j'imagine à Macron empêcher un Macron
qui peut pas se présenter soit par un
scandale sortie du coffre Alexandre
Benalla l'affaire de l'été et non pas
l'affaire d'étapes ou bien un choix
personnel des difficultés avec le la
crise du coronavirus ou autre et un
deuxième tour étonnant où on trouverait
Éric Zemmour face à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Mélenchon qui serait finalement le seul
à gauche capable de faire une union et
tout le monde se rassembler en bon
finalement on a plus que 4 mois allons-y
nous n'avons pas le choix Éric Zemmour
qui frère de la droite avec Valérie
Pécresse qui descendrai dans les
sondages et aurez du mal à imprimer
parce que elle ferait finalement la
suite de Mâcon alors c'est complètement
fou rire dans ce deuxième tour je verrai
pourquoi pas la victoire d'Éric Zemmour
qui lui du coup réussis ré art fédérer
la droite alors que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
bien la gauche est tellement divisée se
ferait évidemment descendre par ses
alliés je sens que les très envie de
radicalité de manière inconsciente
en train de se battre et de faire
exploser le système